[Musik]
er dient
frank walter steinmeier seit fünf jahren
im amt des bundespräsidenten
er steht für deutschland und er steht
ein für deutschlands geschichte der
repräsentiert ein schwieriges land
zu hause und in der welt vor
pickelhauben und gekrönten häuptern
manchmal begegnet er auch aufgeblasenen
vögeln
steinmeier steht über den parteien und
nahe bei den menschen ein
bürgerpräsident
[Musik]
das gehört dazu wenn ein neuer
bundespräsident ein zählten schloss
bellevue nachdem auch die bundeswehr
ihre aufwartung eine ehrenkompanie tritt
an der präsident schreitet sie ab
protokoll rutschte
dann aber wagt steinmeier etwas neues
ganz unerwartetes eine fröhliche ältere
dame begrüßte besonders herzlich seine
mutter steinmeier vergisst nicht woher
er kommt auch nicht im höchsten
staatsamt
das war eine behütete kindheit aber eben
doch ein elternhaus
ohne klavieren bibliothek
und insofern war es tatsächlich ein
weiter weg entscheidend ist glaube ich
dass man sich an den stationen der
veränderung von denen es viele gegeben
hat in meiner biografie
immer wieder klar macht wie wenig
selbstverständlich das ist
steinmeiers elternhaus steht in
ostwestfalen brakelsiek 1000 einwohner
60 km bis bielefeld sein vater tischler
die mutter vertrieben aus schlesien bei
der arbeiten hart und halten sich an die
regeln die große welt ist anderswo
der junge bedarf aufs gymnasium als
erster in seiner familie er macht abitur
keine selbstverständlichkeit in
brakelsiek auch bei meinen eltern gab es
ja bildungs bewusstsein
aber vielleicht gar nicht so sehr
den mut und die entschiedenheit den
jungen aufs gymnasium zu schicken man
ist halt einfach im dorf unüblich war
steinmeier studiert jura was handfestes
politisch engagierte sich bei den jusos
in vorstandsämter aber drängt er nicht
entscheidet sich schließlich für eine
brave beamtenlaufbahn
bis gerhard schröder ihn entdeckt er
macht steinmeier zu seiner rechten hand
erst in hannover dann in berlin als chef
des kanzleramts architekt der agenda
politik den merkels erster großer
koalition über dem steinmeier dann das
außenamt
[Musik]
er kommt aus der sozialdemokratischen
tradition in deutschland und reagiert
deshalb etwas sensibler also die nazi
verbrechen geht um die deutsche
vergangenheit wir waren deshalb oft
einig mit blick auf die geschichte aber
wir sind manchmal unterschiedlicher
ansicht wie man mit putins russland
umgehen soll
dann fordert er merkel heraus
2009 kämpft steinmeier selbst ums
kanzleramt
der vizekanzler aus dem volk begeistert
seine partei ein volkstribun aber ist er
nicht steinmeier verliert
vier jahre müht er sich ab als
fraktionschef der spd oppositionsführer
[Musik]
steinmeier war 2009 kanzlerkandidat der
spd also hochpolitisch und ist jetzt so
überparteilich also keiner verbindet
indirekt mehr mit der spd da ist ja ein
sehr langen weg gegangen und ich finde
es auch sehr gut gemacht
erst mochten nicht alle an ihn glauben
zu beginn seiner amtszeit gilt
steinmeier als kompromiss bequem für die
kanzlerin kandidat der großen koalition
merkel kennt ihn ein politiker denn
anders als vorgänger joachim gauck nicht
die aura der auflehnung gegen die
ddr-diktatur umweht steinmeier
verteidigt die demokratie immer mehr
menschen zweifeln
wer heute in deutschland seien es seinen
sorgen luft macht und dabei ruf wir sind
das volk
der darf das gern aber
der muss auch hinnehmen dass andere
leute mit anderen ansichten diesen
stolzen satz genauso banken vor allem
meine damen und herren will ich eines
dass wir in deutschland festhalten an
dem unterschied von fakt und lüge wird
das aufgibt der rheurdter grundgerüst
von demokratie
zu diesem zeitpunkt sitzt die afg noch
nicht im bundestag wohl aber in vielen
landtagen mit einem zweistelligen
ergebnis bei der bundestagswahl jedoch
ein halbes jahr später rechnet noch
niemand
da ist steinmeier ins amt gekommen und
hat sehr schnell er spürt dass hier
brücken wieder gebaut werden müssen dass
die risse die durch die gesellschaft
gehen die
polarisierung die seitdem noch stärker
geworden ist dass das ein zentrales
thema sein muss die bewährungsprobe
kommt nach der bundestagswahl im
november 2017 platzen jamaika träume
steinmeier wird zum vermittler
[Applaus]
der präsident beherrscht die kunst der
kompromisse und die sozialdemokraten
vertrauen ihm diskret bugsierte die spd
in eine weitere ungeliebte große
koalition und rettet merkel so aus einer
zerfahrenen zwangslage es ist ja die
hohe kunst die frank walter steinmeier
hervorragend beherrscht hier
weichen zu stellen einzuwirken ohne im
vordergrund zu stehen und dazu braucht
man einverständnis des politikbetriebs
seinem thema demokratie bleibt er treu
besucht die wenigen orte demokratische
tradition die deutschland aufzubieten
hat das haben wir verschloss etwa wo
mutige demokraten 1832 einen aufbruch
wagen die obrigkeit beendete ihn schnell
und hart oder die frankfurter
paulskirche
1848 tagt hier das erste deutsche
parlament scheitert unrühmlich
die erste demokratie auf deutschem boden
aber wagen ein paar jakobiner in mainz
1793 nach französischem vorbild an diese
mainzer republik erinnert steinmeier
2018 auch sie hielt kaum 100 tage
wir müssen wieder lernen für demokratie
zu streiten
ein blick in unsere geschichte zeigt auf
einzigartige weise
dass einigkeit und recht und freiheit
alles andere als selbstverständlich sind
wie verwundbar demokratie auch heute
sein kann zeigt sich wenig später
zweimal in kurzer zeit februar 2020 in
hanau ermordet ein schwer bewaffneter
mann innerhalb weniger minuten neun
menschen offenbar aus rassistischem hass
am ende tötet er sich selbst
vier monate zuvor halle ein
rechtsextremist verübt einen
mordanschlag auf die synagoge der stadt
ausgerechnet an yom kippur dem höchsten
jüdischen feiertag
steinmeier besucht den tatort spricht
mit den überlebenden und tritt dann
entsetzt und empört vor die kameras
gestern sind zwei menschen gestorben
[Musik]
ermordet von einem täter der
offensichtlich zu allem
bereit war zwei weitere
sind verletzt worden
unsere gedanken unser mitgefühl sind bei
den angehörigen in einem raum als der
bundespräsident mit seiner frau am tisch
saß mit dem überlebende und das war und
man hat gesehen dass es ehrlich ist dass
er der wattiefe berühren der hat
richtige fragen gestellt er und seine
frau er wollte wirklich wissen von der
jüdischen gemeinde was konnte man machen
damit so ein schreckliches ding nie
wieder passiert
nur die schwere eingangstür hat das
blutbad im gotteshaus verhindert der
bundespräsident macht diese tür später
zum thema seiner weihnachtsansprache
diese angegriffene eingangstür zur
synagoge
sie steht in meinen augen für noch mehr
sie steht auch für uns wir brauchen die
demokratie aber ich glaube
derzeit braucht die demokratie vor allem
uns
steinmeier auf staatsbesuch überall in
der welt bunter als die nüchternen
arbeitstreffen des außenministers oder
bundespräsident auftritt erklingt musik
er zeigt flagge vor prachtvollen pagoden
ebenso wie in flüchtlingslagern
politisch aber muss er sich nun bedeckt
halten
handlungsreisender in sachen demokratie
jedoch bleibt der präsident
[Musik]
in kolumbien etwa wo er schon als
außenminister einen fragilen frieden
vorbereitet hat nach ecuador reisen der
bundespräsident und die first lady auf
den spuren des naturforschers alexander
von humboldt auch ein abstecher auf die
galapagos inseln gehört dazu
aufgeblasenen iv regeln hier nähert
steinmeier sich unbefangen einer
begegnung mit donald trump jedoch peter
lieber aus dem weg
reisen nach israel gehören zu den
schwierigsten missionen eines deutschen
präsidenten mögen manche begegnungen wie
beim spontanen wir mit israels präsident
rieflin auch ungezwungen erscheinen
lange schatten lagen hinein in diese
freundschaft
das menschheitsverbrechen der shoah h
millionenfachen mord an menschen
jüdischen glaubens verübt von deutschen
überall in europa inbegriff des
schreckens das deutsche
vernichtungslager auschwitz
[Musik]
zur gedenkfeier am 75 jahrestag der
befreiung von auschwitz darf in
jerusalem auch steinmeier sprechen als
erstes deutsches staatsoberhaupt in der
israelischen gedenkstätte jad vaschem
die sprache der täter
[Applaus]
wurden
ich hatte richtige gänsehaut aber
positive gänsehaut weil das das war so
ein ein star muss wo ich gesagt habe war
und das war für ihn wahrscheinlich nicht
sehr leicht als deutscher präsident nach
mike pence nach emanuel makor und
wladimir putin die stelle zu nehmen und
diese rede zu halten
das publikum jubelte und die
israelischen medien haben es natürlich
zum thema auch gemacht
ein paar tage später besuchte
bundespräsident den schauplatz des
terrors gedenkstätte auschwitz unweit
von krakau staats- und regierungschefs
aus aller welt gedenken der opfer des
völkermords
auf dem rückflug nach berlin begrüßt
steinmeier an bord seines airbus einen
gast bleiben rief israels präsident in
einem flugzeug der luftwaffe auf dem weg
in die deutsche hauptstadt geste der
freundschaft und des vertrauens
es hat auch wirklich gezeigt wie tief
diese freundschaft geht ich meine auch
wenn man wenn man den präsident
ehemaligen präsidenten mit dem
bundespräsident steinmeier in einem raum
sieht sieht man wirklich dass es eine
echte freundschaft ist es ist nicht nur
für die journalisten gemacht
anlässlich der gedenkfeier des
bundestages spricht regieren dann auch
vor dem deutschen parlament
[Applaus]
wenn in deutschland der versuch
scheitert hüter der schwelle am tor zu
sein liberale werte gegen populismus zu
verteidigen dann ist er überall zum
scheitern verurteilt wenn juden nicht
mehr frei sein können dort wo die shoah
geschehen ist dann werden juden
nirgendwo in europa und in der welt ohne
angst leben können
wenige tage später kommen aus china
erste berichte über infektionen mit
einem neuartigen
hochansteckenden virus kaum einer ahnt
dass damit eine der schwersten krisen
beginnt die deutschland und die welt je
erschüttert haben co wird 19 das corona
virus macht millionen menschen krank
hunderttausende trifft es tödlich
politiker wirken überrumpelt verhängen
strenge kontakt sperren lockdown ein
land macht dicht zu ostern wendet sich
der bundespräsident im fernsehen an
seine landsleute
die pandemie zeigt uns ja wir sind
verwundert
vielleicht haben wir zu lange geglaubt
dass wir unverwundbar sind dass es immer
nur schneller höher weiter geht aber das
war ein irrtum die krise zeigt uns
allerdings nicht nur das sie zeigt uns
auch wie stark wir sind worauf wir bauen
können viele bürger aber verlieren das
vertrauen tausende demonstrieren gegen
die korona maßnahmen nennen sich
querdenker radikale vor allem von rechts
kapern den protest und stellen die
demokratische ordnung ganz grundsätzlich
in frage ende august 2020 versuchen
einige in den reichstag einzudringen die
polizei kann den sturm auf das parlament
gerade noch verhindern rechtsextreme
blogger aber stellen bilder der
bedrängten beamten prahlerisch ins
internet
der bundespräsident verurteilt die
angriffe scharf berliner polizisten die
sich der aufgepeitschten menge tapfer
entgegengestellt hatten empfängt in
bellevue ich hätte mir gewünscht dass
der bundespräsident in der korona krise
vielleicht noch präsenter gewesen wäre
aber man darf nicht vergessen wir hatten
eine omnipräsente
präsidiale kanzlerin mit angela merkel
die kaum platz gelassen hat so kann man
es vielleicht auch sehen aber trotzdem
etwas mehr präsenz in der korona krise
hätte ich mir persönlich zumindest
gewünscht
in diesen tagen neigt steinmeiers erste
amtszeit sich ihrem ende entgegen sein
wunsch weiter zu machen hat der
präsident früh bekundet in der
bundesversammlung die zur
präsidentenwahl alle fünf jahre im
reichstag zusammen kommt kann er mit
einer stabilen mehrheit rechnen
eine zweite amtszeit scheint deshalb
sicher die demokratie aber steinmeiers
großes thema wird verunsichert wie schon
lange nicht mehr vieles bleibt zu tun
man muss ja auch in die zukunft schauen
und bundespräsident steinmeier ist
jemand der das auch macht aber man
sollte mal auch wirklich dieses thema
von antisemitismus ernst nehmen und
alles tun damit dieses ding auf hat er
ist jemand der den schwerpunkt nicht nur
aufs zuhören sondern eben auch auf die
klaren worte richtet der den dialog
sucht der eben eine wie ich finde ein
inklusiver brückenbauer sein möchte und
der dass dem thema demokratie ganz ins
herzstück seiner amtszeit rückt
auch der frieden in europa der so lange
so sicher schien wirkt brüchig zurück
ist die sorge vor einem aggressiven
russland besonders im osten europas lang
verdrängte ängste sind auf einmal wieder
da
ich denke steinmeier macht seinen job
gut aber man kann nie genug tun um den
polen zu versichern dass die deutschen
nicht vergessen was sie in polen
angerichtet haben im zweiten weltkrieg
das mag alles lange her sein aber diese
wunden schmerzen habe
juni fällt
unsichere zeiten komplizierter
vielleicht als steinmeier zu beginn
seiner ersten amtszeit ahnen mochte mehr
denn je wird es nun darauf ankommen dass
der mann in schloss bellevue die
richtigen worte findet worte vor allem
verleihen dem am seine kraft ganz
besonders in schwierigen zeiten